c'est drôle hein quand on vous annonce a
quand même hein c'est à la fois à
l'époque leur vision avait une place
très très très importante et la france
n'avait pas gagné depuis neuf ans c'est
la française marie myriam qui a remporté
hier soir le grand prix eurovision de la
chanson le triomphe de marie myriam hier
soir à londres
mon défi en fait j'ai l'habitude de dire
que c'était mon triple salto arrière
bassetti les huit premières mesures a
capella plus personne n'a jamais refait
sa l'eurovision d'ailleurs comme un
enfant aux yeux de lumière qui doit
passer au loin les oiseaux comme
l'oiseau bleu survolant la terre voit
comme le monde le monde est beau vous
savez cette chanson 45 ans après les
toujours d'actualité le texte a
abandonné et dinoire la misère les
hommes et la guerre et on y est quoi et
c'est un c'est un message de paix
vraiment
[Musique]
pour réveiller
la ville de nous
malin faya
pour nous l'honneur
j'ai pas pu dîner ce soir là on a eu un
dîner après avec tous les candidats et
tous les accompagnant et en fait chaque
fois que je
avec la pochette j'essaie de manger
quelque chose on me disait
congratulaient josé donc je pose ma
fourchette et jeu serré les mains et en
fait on m'enlevait assiette en 1977 il y
avait seulement dix huit participants ce
qui a changé c'est en terme de show et
je préfère aujourd'hui parce que je
trouve que c'est vraiment une soirée
très américaine et est vrai c'est très
chaud le concours était retransmis dans
33 pays devant 300 millions d'hommes et
de femmes qui attendent d'eux que la
junte entend pas t'entendre ta petite de
bois pour nous parler d'amour et des
libertés en 2022 il ya quarante
participants et le concours est
retransmis dans 41 pays
45 ans après marie myriam la france va
tenter de gagner une sixième fois
l'eurovision la 40 pays ça fait beaucoup
donc je sais pas dire qu'elle est la
meilleure place je pense juste que c'est
peut-être
le chanteur d'avant la chanson d'avant
et la chanson d'après qui peut balayer
la prestation d'un pays aujourd'hui
marie myriam reste la dernière gagnante
française de l'eurovision
[Musique]